welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and morbius was a movie leaving us
questioning whether we all saw the same
indian of spider-man no way home or if
some folks might have seen an
international re-edit of no way home
that alters the logic of the memory wipe
spell because for some markets worldwide
gaslighting hits a little spider-man
close to home i am going to do my best
to answer your questions about the
ending and post-credits scenes of
morbius but spoiler warning before i
continue i guess even though the
director of this movie a week ago
clarified stuff about the post-credits
scene on twitter
why so morbius has two post-credits
scenes both including michael keaton
adrian toombs after he and nearly every
spider-man reference we saw in trailers
for this movie were removed from the
final cut of the main film so dr michael
morbius suffering from a blood disorder
develops a serum from human and bat dna
that gives him vampiric powers a serum
stolen by his old friend another guy
suffering from this disorder and the
thunder of his research lucian aka milo
lucian steals the serum frames michael
for the murder sending him to prison but
then after michael figures out it was
him he breaks out and battles lucian in
the subway and then fearing from his own
increasing need for blood and what
lucian might do with these powers
michael develops a new serum to kill
living vampires lucian kills their
mentor played by jared harris and
injures martine michael has to bite
martine to save her life but also
powering himself up leading to an aerial
battle in new york that goes down into
the sewers where michael summons a swarm
of bats to pin down lucian and hit him
with that serum martine wakes up herself
now a living vampire then on to the
credits which gives us more mcu
connectivity than we really know what to
do with in the first scene we see a
nighttime shot of manhattan with purple
rifts streaking through the sky same as
the ones in the final battle of
spider-man no way home then shot inside
a prison facility of light streaming
through a cell window and inside that
cell is michael keaton adrian toomes
last seen in spider-man homecoming a
movie set in the mcu the glow fades and
he touches himself in disbelief looking
at his reflection in the glass mirror
that they definitely install in prisoner
cells and says to himself hope the
food's better in this joint then we got
to a report from new york spectrum one
news a bizarre story developing at the
manhattan detention center when a man
identifying himself as adrian toombs
simply appeared in an otherwise empty
cell a hearing has been set that could
likely lead to his immediate release top
story there not the giant purple cracks
in the sky hey it's new york then
footage of tombs being escorted out of
the prison into an suv for that hearing
likely footage from the scene where in
the trailers he crossed paths with
michael morbius michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up doc
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
again an interaction that was not in the
main film then we cut to black and then
on to the second post-credit scene
morbius drives a sports car out to a
remote location he checks his watch the
wind blows and tombs swoops in with the
vulture suit that we saw in spider-man
homecoming but it does look slightly
different it's a bit more rickety and
his oxygen mask is now pointed to look
like a vulture beak he says thanks for
meeting me doc i've been reading about
you morbius says i'm listening tomb says
i'm not sure how i got here has to do
with spider-man i think i'm still
figuring this place out but i think a
bunch of guys like us should team up do
some good and morbius responds
intriguing now it is clear that sony's
intention is to set up a sinister six
film finally even confirmed by the
director to cinemablend he also
confirmed that this movie is set in the
universe of venom and venom let there be
carnage the same universe eddie brock
returned to in that no way home
post-credits scene thus morbius's
reference to venom in his joke earlier
and the director confirmed that this
universe has a spider-man in it but
would not yet say which one only that
quote it is my understanding that
audiences will discover that answer soon
since toby maguire's universe had its
own venom and since he signals that they
see the mcu as a distinctly separate
universe that leaves andrew garfield as
the likeliest option of the spider-man
of this universe which after no way home
is something we'd all definitely love to
see but the spider-man of this universe
could also be a live-action miles
morales who was alluded to by andrew
garfield peter parker and max dillon's
exchange in no way home i just thought
she was gonna be black oh man i'm sorry
i don't pause that there's gotta be a
black spider-man somewhere out there but
it's also possible that both andrew
garfield and miles morales could be
introduced in this future sinister six
film a film that'll likely also include
craven hunter and maybe also chameleon
black cat scorpion rhino and madame webb
all characters that sony is actively
developing now using experimental
bat-based medicine to cure yourself can
have some unexpected consequences and
negative side effects similarly the
electronics we use every day have big
negative side effects they turn into
e-waste when you throw electronics away
they become e-waste which represents
almost 70 percent of the global toxic
waste output a great way to help keep
toxic e-waste out of landfills is by
purchasing renewed electronics and our
friends at backmarket have built an
amazing marketplace that offers expertly
renewed smartphones laptops and other
tech for a fraction of the normal cost
we've been using this sweet 2020 rose
gold ipad air from back market and i
love it it looks brand new it costs way
less than buy new and it didn't turn
into e-waste that's a sweet tablet every
purchase comes with a one year warranty
30 days to change your mind and free
standard shipping plus with backmarket's
new buyback program you can also sell
your old tech for cash use code rockstar
and save 20 on your first purchase of
expertly renewed tech that's an extra 20
off an already great deal so break up
with new tech and find your next device
at backmarket.com that's back market not
black market however we should also note
that tombs and morbius's team up was to
quote do some good and they did not
directly antagonize spider-man so maybe
tomb still has some good will for
spider-man for saving his life and
homecoming and they might actually help
him against the sinister six but how did
tombs acquire his vulture suit if he
transported into this universe merely in
his prison or jumpsuit well the director
said only that it's not quite the same
suit as homecoming he is a resourceful
guy okay
but the whole point of spider-man
homecoming is that tombs and his crew
built weapons out of chittari tech taken
after the battle of new york they
weren't building this kind of weaponry
otherwise the core theme of spider-man
homecoming was that the avengers actions
had street-level consequences one of
whom was spider-man and the problems he
had to deal with so without chitari tech
in this universe how would tombs be able
to reassemble the wings from a box of
scraps
why really the bigger question is how
adrian tombs even arrived to this
universe because according to spiderman
no way home the flawed runes of cough
calls spell transports people who know
peter parker as spider-man from other
universes into the reality where that
spell was cast the mcu and at the end of
that movie all those intruders were
returned to their home realities but
adrian toombs was already in the mcu the
mcu is his home reality there's no
reason he should have been transported
out of the reality where the spell was
cast into some other random reality and
no reason for him to stay in that other
random reality forever after doctor
strange finished the spell at the very
least he should have gone back home the
director tried to explain quote at the
end of venom let there be carnage in
spiderman no way home and in no way home
itself it is clearly established that it
is possible for characters to transfer
from one universe to another the events
of no way home had the effect of
transferring venom and vulture and maybe
others back and forth between the mcu
and the venom universe uh-huh obviously
that was not clearly established at all
but he uses the words back and forth so
i guess according to this new logic it
doesn't matter that the spell was cast
in the mcu and it doesn't matter that dr
strange patched it those purple cracks
just represent a kind of revolving door
through which anyone who knew peter with
spider-man on either side of that
barrier could randomly transport in
either direction i mean dude by your
logic those others stolen from the mcu
by the venomverse now in those
neighboring cells beside tombs could be
hulk or thor or wong i mean why not take
everyone sony
i just pray that madame webb gives us a
better explanation like perhaps all
peter parkers are connected by such a
strong shared arachno frequency that
andrew garfield peter parker emitted a
kind of magnetism that drew back with
him into the venomverse someone in the
mcu who knew that peter was spider-man
in this case adrian toombs i mean who
knows maybe it was even orchestrated by
madame webb to balance the cosmic scales
because she knew that peter and miles
would need adrian toombs more than tom
holland would need him i mean i don't
know i don't really care just give us
something more than
why you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis and attempts to analyze
everything that you love or maybe don't
love either way thank you for watching
bye
[Music]
you